if you left the theater feeling a little
disappointed by the Lion King remake one
fan artist has just the remedy for your
blues Digital Artist and photoshop
wizard Nikolaj Moscone who goes by the
username at LJ art on Instagram has
reimagined the Lion King characters as
they're seen in the new film and drawn
them in a style more closely aligned
with the original movie originally
voiced by Jonathan Taylor Thomas young
Simba is played by JD McCreary and
director Jon Favreau's remake and he
doesn't just sound different either gone
are the exaggerated eye movements head
tilts winces and smiles that Simba
expressed in the 90s movie
replaced instead by a lion who looks
real enough to reach out and touch but
isn't really as emotive as before much
kin brought back Simba signature sass
and his reworking of the characters
design adding in downturned brows when
the young lion cub knows he's in trouble
and giving him wider eyes as he looks
out at the vast expanse of the pride
lands adult Simba also got a retouch
from watch kin who gave the remakes
version of the lion his orange tinged
mane bright eyes and expressive face
from the original film and though she's
voiced by multi Grammy Award winning
artist and chart-topping
singer-songwriter Beyonce this time
around
Simba's childhood friend turned Queen
Nala still wasn't perfect by Machens
estimations he made her eyes brighter
and bluer her muzzle squarer and her
eyes larger and lower than before to sum
the biggest mistake the Lion King remake
made was dampening the menacing presence
of Simba's villainous uncle Scar voice
after chiwetel ejiofor known for his
work in films like twelve years a slave
and dr. strange did a pretty bang-up job
making Skaar sound as vicious as Jeremy
Irons did in the original Lion King but
most people felt that Disney's animators
failed to depict the mangy lion in all
his sinister wickedness
[Music]
much can however aim to fix that he
reimagined scar with his trademark black
mane dark sienna coat yellow eyes and a
scar that runs down his forehead and
cheek on top of all that much can even
reworked the poster for the Lion King in
which Simba and his ragtag guardians
Timon and Pumbaa look far more
expressive than they did before though
it was marketed as much Disney's
live-action remake of The Lion King
wasn't actually live-action at all
it certainly was a remake though
essentially taking the exact shots used
in the animated original and reimagining
them in photorealistic CGI animation the
end result was visually stunning but it
was also lacking a certain something
which many critics felt was the nuanced
emotion present in the 1994 version of
The Lion King hmm
talk about your fixer-upper the edits
that much can create it are sure to
appease the fans who might have found
themselves disappointed by the lion
Kings remake but they may also do
something better still motivate Disney
to hold off on just pumping out
live-action remakes of its classic
animated films and take a moment to
actually consider what the best approach
could be there's no doubt that the
nostalgia factor behind the Lion King
pulled audiences to theaters in their
droves and it paid off to the new Lion
King made over 595 million dollars
worldwide as of July 25th 2019 but
box-office bucks can only take a studio
so far and de fewers aren't joyously
picking up what it's putting down it
might just be time for Disney to figure
out a plan to keep its future
live-action remakes from getting hit
with the same rotten review is that the
Lion King did and if that never happens
well at least we got some cool artwork
out of it check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bells so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]